listen pretzel you better show up on
time otherwise that's a real dough
breaker for me
canceling plans I don't really have that
many dough breakers it's really about
just really getting to know somebody
hello I'm Hannah Hart and this is edible
history today we're going to be
unknotting the origins of the pretzel
personally I love pretzels I can't get
enough of them I love the salt I love
the shape I love the design there's such
an aesthetically pleasing baked good not
talking to you pretzel rods I mean like
loosen up your nerds but where do the
pretzels come from have they always been
as naughty as they appear today we'll be
talking about all this and more with
pretzel expert William boys Weaver I
love everything about pretzels but I
know nothing about them what can you
tell me about the origins of what we
know to be a pretzel today the pretzel
is actually pre-christian origin
pretzels were made all over Celtic
Europe they were often made with wheat
and woven into that particular shape
which is known as a harvest not the
Germans assimilated this custom from the
Celtic peoples who lived there it was
connected with human sacrifice in the
pagan period and so the pretzel is a
symbolic noose how did this seemingly
dark baked goods come into popularity
today there are a lot of strange stories
associated with the pretzel every Baker
had to learn to make pretzels because
this was a symbol of the baking trade so
it was a trade secret you had to get it
from a bakery the pretzel Baker's
decided that they were going to clean up
the pretzels image and they made up this
strange story about how the pretzel was
invented by a monk they tried to give it
up churchy
if you will cleaned up image talking
about pretzels is making me pretty
hungry can you tell me a little bit
about the recipe that we'll be making
today you're going to be making the
Munich live pretzels but in the old days
you had a guy who was really well built
and he'd beat the crap out of fact our
dough and this broke down gluten and
made that the dough very spongy then you
start to tie it into your pretzel shape
there's a real art to making the pretzel
perfect I've got a tall order ahead of
me but I think I think I'm ready to do
it
[Music]
so today we'll be making the moocher
logan bretzel which means munich lie
pretzel this recipe comes from a pretzel
cookbook published in 1922 and it's
pretty simple we're just gonna be using
flour yeast water and a lot of lye first
we add fresh yeast and mix it with a
little warm water now it's likely that
the early Baker's use the yeast made
from beer we're using a yeast made from
wherever this came from okay and then
we're just gonna mix it until it
dissolves mmm smell that activation now
we'll be adding our spelt flour suppose
B's pretty easy you could say it's spelt
out for me okay we're gonna combine our
spelt with our yeast mmm now you'll
notice that we're not adding any salt to
this initial dough that's because we
don't want the salt to kill the east we
want this yeast to thrive and now to the
kneading just a warm satisfying now for
you most avid edible history fans you'll
know this isn't my first dough so I
don't really know if we need any more
jokes about it now that we're done
kneading we are going to set our door
side and take it out when it's ripe well
that just means to let it rise may she
rise you guys want to join my cool
pretzel cult that's what we're all about
and we're back all right let's take a
look
Oh beautiful now that our yeast has done
its job it's time to add the salt for
flavor so we're gonna be making a little
bit of a salt water mixture over here to
add it back into the dough I mean so far
this recipe seems pretty spot-on you
know with a way they made pretzels back
then seems a lot like how we make
pretzels today ah tastes like tears just
tell the pig and gods like it now we add
our water to our dough let's give it a
little love it feels a little bit like
making slime it's kind of like the
saltwater is eating the dough but maybe
we'll hit a turning point the salt water
appears to have turned our dough into
clay like texture yeah I don't know if
we're gonna get a pretzel out of this so
let's try again with less salt water Wow
beautiful so now we're gonna be using
substantially less water with the same
amount of salt to flavor our bread now
this is much much more like it okay so
our salt is incorporated but if this
dough still isn't the easiest to work
with so it's time to bring in the dough
breaker
[Music]
do my own stunts
okay now this is where the recipe starts
to take some twists and turns
by making twists turns our next step is
to take a little chunk of our pretzel
dough and we're gonna be rolling it into
our pretzel shape so what we're doing
here is we're leaving a little bit of
thickness in the center while rolling
out the ends of our dough it gets a
little thick you can roll out the center
just a little bit but you really want to
make sure that your ends are longer and
thinner than your Center bit and then we
make a little bit of a u-shape
we twist then we twist again and then we
put it in to a pretzel hooray that my
friends is a harvest not all right
perfect so we're gonna make some more
set them aside to let them rise for just
a little bit and then we get to the
boiling and the baking
oh for that I'm gonna need some safety
gear
[Music]
hello up next we'll be working with a
caustic chemical known as lye map really
do not try this at home it is very
dangerous we have taken extra safety
precautions if you really want to do it
you could use an alternative of baking
soda and that's all I have to say about
that because it's really hot inside this
mask so let's let's get started taking
cold water and using a ratio of 1 to 20
we are ready to add our lye the live
serves the purpose of acting as a mold
deterrent so that you could store the
pretzels for longer now that we've added
our lye we're gonna bring it to a boil
and then start adding our pretzels going
to boil our pretzels for 30 seconds
we're just gonna scoop them up and give
them a quick dip this is what Baker's
call spray-tanning
the skin's not gonna look darker now but
the reaction will be completed in the
oven and that's it oh man I'm not gonna
lie you guys this has been stressful and
last but not least we're gonna sprinkle
and with salt
did you do oh yeah yeah yeah now we take
our pretzels off to bake and after
baking they'll be safe for human
consumption so if we've finished baking
our pretzels in a well-ventilated oven I
mean look at how good these look are
they today's pretzels no but you know
they got a shine to them the salt looks
like it's well-maintained they smell
like a freshly baked thing and last but
not least the final moment time to taste
okay
feels like a pretzel
[Music]
tastes like popcorn that's very
surprising they don't have the same kind
of like soft buoyancy as today's
pretzels do but I mean if you want to
preserve this thing till the fall I can
totally see how well what have we
learned on our pretzel journey one
making pretzels super hard and do they
taste like popcorn thanks so much for
watching the season finale of edible
history what do you think would you eat
one of these pretzels
you